[Music]
in Instant Karma news oh I love it
Instant Karma news what are we gonna do
now submitted by a lot of people a lot
of people it was just that was their
name oh oh but not a lot of people
submitted it uh three guys beat the [__]
out of a man who tried to carjack them
Oh
why would you carjack someone who's with
three people in the car when you're by
yourself maybe he had a gun and he
thinks he's like so invincible I read
the story he's a [__] idiot go ahead
I'm gonna be the guys are really really
skinny petite guys but little did he
know they were Muay Thai fighters like
professional mm-hmm so this this guy his
name is Angelo 20 years old from
Albuquerque New Mexico that's where they
make for the DBQ mm-hmm that's also
where Elmer Fudd lives
Albuquerque Angelo here he was hanging
around this area where these football
players were having practice and so it
sounds bad mm-hmm one of these players
they notice that he was lingering near
their car a lot like trying to get in
he's being shady so then they approached
Angelo and that's when Angelo was like
oh I just I need a ride like can you
guys give me a ride so then these three
football players had just gotten out of
practice they were like all right cool
give you a ride these high school or
collegiate actually are professional
they just say for their ages well he's
20 I don't know the other guy
yeah they don't really and then with a
place where they were where he was near
it was a Loma Linda Community Center
okay it's not really so we don't know
here but the football players yeah and
they're usually pretty burly looking
unless you're football players from
couple and you're five foot one thousand
nine pounds I'm nice you're football
players from like Samoa then you're like
six six then their heads are sticking
out of the windows yeah the roots
yeah okay so then that's when they were
like alright cool we'll give you good
you're right so they all get in the car
and then Angelo kept changing the
direction of his destination so I got to
the point where the car was stopped he
pulls out a gun call you called it he
tells them he forces a jerk move
[__] yeah he forces the three
guys to get out of the car
so they do and then when he was trying
to drive off stupid car he lost grip of
the gun somehow stupid so then one of
the football players punched him and
then that's when the other guys joined
in and then they just beat him to a pulp
all I'm saying it's how [__] stupid
are you to Jack a car from three
football players you might as well go to
a UFC gym and try to jack them during
prime time work hours yeah hilarious he
looks dumb as [__] you know what's
[__] up oh he is these guys were nice
enough to give you a [__] ride
they're nice enough to give you a
[__] ride dude shouldn't that give
you faith in humanity where you go I was
gonna steal from you guys
but you're kind of cool yeah three guys
and I'll probably never do it again yeah
those eyebrows were like half hyphens no
you're stupid yeah bad choices and
tattoos and graduates isn't eyebrows
those aren't even real Lopes you guys
wanna see what it look like after yes
wider looks like a grey alien you go
back you can't even open his eyes his
eyes look like sideways fat [__]
that's amazing sadly it's not [__]
yet
yeah eyebrows are still look at him
awesome stupid that's awesome it's like
I gotta try to to rob a gun store and
then he got shot [__] dude Nick was
gonna happen [__] this guy's a [__]
dumb [__] I love Instant Karma that was
beautifully done I want to see what the
football players look like oh no picture
yeah I love dumb criminals
those guys are just the best mm-hmm and
apparently they found out that the gun
was fake and the football players found
a knife tucked in his waistband so he
when he got arrested he was charged with
four counts of aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon and attempt to commit a
felony good you try to rob three people
with a fake gun
football players oh my god yeah and
apparently in his past he's had charges
of auto theft and shoplifting [__]
dummy what a waste of space I like I
like dumb criminals because I make it so
easy to catch him so it's so stupid like
my friend from Japan and got stationed
in Texas and he brought his trip car
over within the first week or so got
stolen
and then he was just heartbroken in a
week later the [__] dumbass that
stole it took it to a car show did an
illegal burnout out of the show right in
front of a cop
so so the cop pulls him over and then
realizes oh this is a stolen car like
you're so [__] still I love stupid
panels they're so awesome how do you cut
I just want to know how he was beat
because like he was probably repeatedly
punched in the [__] forehead to have
no more like we all have little dips
that go in right yeah
- it was one big forehead that went like
from I it was in his head how do you
turn into a grey alien balloon he looks
like what's-his-name from Herrick and
add it his ears are [__] like it's
like a balloon like it's just
everything's face look like it exploded
go back to the other one the first one
without the Hat okay
his head looks like it's a small head
that's a good food or do you think it's
the angle to make it look like it's
smaller than what it is like he's got
brain damage he's lucky he didn't die no
I was thinking this thinks I'm like
three football players knowing and on
you because you just pulled a gun on
that what if there were three punters oh
my god yeah I just imagined three
football guys like circled around him
just like kicking him no no a punter is
usually the smallest guy on the team
yeah but I'm also thinking like cuz if
if someone robbed me and it was like to
my friends after we beat him down if I
continued stomping on I'm probably
probably died yeah what's that gash on
his forehead is it like split open yeah
you know what something once they're no
longer a threat you can get in trouble
so if you continue beating them yeah so
just just let them hold on to the fake
gun while you [__] them up and then let
them pick up the gun again and then you
[__] them all hmm yes that's that's
gonna record at all so you're in the
clear mm-hmm I'd be surprised if he knew
his rights though wait did this happen
in Albuquerque yes yes oh man I was
surprised too like there's pretty brave
the football players who just jump him
like that when he thought he had a real
gun that's pretty crazy but you said he
lost grip of a gun right well yeah he
just jumped onto opportunity when they
sold it maybe you had fast reaction
times you know they just came from
practice what they're doing like that
so he was just ready already yeah cuz
this guy's not very smart like oh I
forgot to mention another funny thing
too was that they also found a note that
he that he wrote very poorly so this is
what he wrote his own oh he put it in
his pocket so police office in my name
is when they don't forget found this
note that says give me the keys to your
whip WIP
and nobody get heart I know
don't make me killed
well they just beat him dumber oh he's
so dumb ya [__] idiot
if I was his friend like if I was one of
his gang friends I would just make fun
of it until he leaves
that's the saddest should have ever seen
he just needs to go to school he
couldn't spell whip or whether there's a
lack you wrote heart H a RT age OHA
aren't you it's heart rate really so
hard like H II like heart oh like an
actual heart instead of like okay cuz I
thought he was trying to spell hurt but
the you turn into a a maybe he's a
romantic bug
yeah the Brits love letters all the
times who's this is China you don't want
to get yeah and all sorts of evidence on
his ass yeah give me the keys to your
whip whip whip whip WIP
WIP equipped oh my god what what is that
all a whip
oh no it's not a it's not a whip it's a
it's a what wait why no English I was
just looking done he still felt it
phonetically all stupid there's no
excuse for heart though I don't know
you know what's pretty bold about the
guy though hmm
she's a lone ranger he's going out there
committing crimes on his own sometimes
you get some point with a fake gun alone
dumbass that's kind of brave he gets a
little bit of street cred he's I
wouldn't give it to him cuz he's really
dumb yeah he's just a reckless dumb guy
if you're alone dumbass teenager like
1099 three six players yeah he does not
ball didn't wanna he didn't want to pick
on someone that's weaker than him he
wanted a challenge
Baltar's being dumb it's book I'm gonna
lean towards dumbest book saying maybe
he caught himself like he just got
himself in that situation cuz the
football players went up to him and he
said what are you doing he was like oh I
need a ride what am I gonna do next T
new directions yeah I was gonna give him
this note but [__] yeah and then he's
like you gotta make a right go in here
you live at jack-in-the-box
it's embarrassing I can't tell them it's
three of them but I got a gun let's do
it
alright come on come on I don't want to
give you a hug went in the car like who
do you even point the gun at like freeze
get out the driver and damn probably to
the tribe yeah you're point out the
driver this guy would just take you out
sounds like what do you what do you do
maybe he got out of the car like all
right bye guys just kidding he turns
around points it from the outside and
they get out of the car or I'll shoot
your friend but then then they can just
run them over but they just run off no
like there may be more I would be more
scared of it's pretty quick to pull a
trigger instead of me putting my car and
driving and driving yeah vegans are
shooting from behind hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
news and if there's a story that you
guys want us to talk about go ahead down
into our description box below and
there's a link there where you can
submit articles for the next video click
right up
[Music]